visit bobwoodward.com
angela davis presents a critical edition
of frederick douglass's memoir narrative
of the life of frederick douglass an
american slave written by himself
ms davis explores the abolitionist's
intellectual life and recalls the
several other editions of douglas's
memoir
angela davis is joined in conversation
by nobel and pulitzer prize-winning
author tony morrison at the new york
public library in new york city the
program is just under two hours
good
evening good evening
hi tony
hi angela
i'm sorry about that entrance
i wondered i wasn't doing it for
theatrics
but i do have a brand new spanking new
hip
ah
i love it i love it i love it
but the rest of the body hasn't caught
up yet
so we go slow
so nobody's moderating us no we're just
talking we're talking we're just talking
we're talking about um
douglas
libraries literacy literacy and
liberation
yes yes absolutely
let me start uh with literacy
because i have this document here which
i want
you know other people to uh know about
we'll read it
i'm interested obviously in literacy i
am impressed
with
what i've only recently discovered which
was that this country
is unique in the world
in terms of the distribution of
libraries throughout the country
uh you cannot go in rural areas
in europe
or in africa or in asia rural areas and
find libraries the way you can here
every little town
not to speak of the huge
university libraries that just jump up
out of nowhere in indiana or someplace
in pennsylvania you go for 100 miles and
there it is you know this enormous
university with more books actually than
cambridge or the libraries in rome
so it's really an extraordinary thing
the other thing is
about literacy which
i'm sort of interested in
is uh
on the one hand the power
of reading
and of course
understanding the meaning
of what one reads
and what i like to think of as visual
literacy
visual literacy
which in addition to print or maybe
without print what do people who are
literally
illiterate do
to negotiate around the world
minus people
who
they depend on
and i don't mean just
uneducated people i mean people
like myself say in beijing and i don't
read the language
i don't understand it how do you
negotiate
and what are the visual signs that you
need to travel the colors
the shapes
uh the sounds
smells all the other senses
and it makes for if you have that plus
the ability to read you have this third
dimension an artist's true dimension
of how to read your world
as well as how to read text
and i wanted to begin
because i wanted to describe
the i don't know explosive
the the perception
of reading
particularly certain kinds of novels
as not just
explosive in a dangerous sense but
explosive in a way that could be lethal
and my documentation for this
angela
is this
thing that paul made me bring for my
house
in my guest bathroom
you know downstairs by the front door
oh
that one
over the sink
is a letter from stuart alin
and asking me would i be
willing to come
and receive the nobel prize for
literature
and write
a speech
on the opposite end over the toilet
is this
i know i said
i've seen this many times
in your bathroom tony
well what it is it was sent to me by uh
an editor
from canap
it's the
the title is the publication denial
notification
the title of the publication is paradise
by me
the above publication has been reviewed
and denied
in accordance with section 3.9
of the
tdc rules and regulations for the
reasons checked below
now there are five reasons
why
a book would be banned from the
texas department of criminal justice
the first reason is the publication
contains contraband
the second one is publication contains
information regarding the manufacture of
explosives weapons or drugs
the
fourth one is a specific factual
determination has been made
that the publication is detrimental to
prisoners rehabilitation
because it would encourage deviant
criminal
sexual behavior
and the last one
publication contains material
on the setting up and operation of
criminal schemes or how to avoid
detection or
of criminal schemes by lawful
authorities charged with the
responsibility for detecting such
illegal activity and i skipped the third
one because that's the one that paradise
is accused of
a publication contains material
that a reasonable person
would construe
as written solely
for the purpose of communicating
information designed to achieve a
breakdown
not just your average breakdown but
a breakdown of prisons
through
inmate disruption
such as strikes or riots
this is um
[Music]
february 20th right after my birthday
1998. i was amused to get this but i was
also thrilled it seemed like an
extraordinary compliment
that paradise could actually
blow up into a riot in a prison
so i thought in addition to my inquiry
about expanding literacy to visual
literacy as well as print
i wanted to make some connection between
prisons
their organization
uh
and the prohibition
and what they understand to be um
lethal and dangerous like
reading
like literacy
like understanding it
and i actually wanted to begin
on that theme
by talking a bit about the
inaccessibility of libraries
and i i'm thinking about my own
childhood
when
i saw this incredible
building in birmingham alabama
made out of indiana limestone it was it
was the
birmingham public library but of course
it was only for white people
the one black library that existed was
run down very few books and i tell the
story
because
i first entered
the doors of this library in 1959
and i can remember how it felt to
actually
walk into
a real library because although i had
used the library in birmingham
it was
very lacking in resources it was broken
down finally they built a new one um
years later yeah many many years later
so
i think
that as we talk about the democratic
impulse of libraries and
and the accessibility of libraries it's
also important to
talk about those places where books have
a hard
time penetrating and your example of the
texas state uh
correctional system is one
just before the event
i had an opportunity to look at some of
the items from the archival collections
here
and i saw
i saw
a wonderful collection
of
a periodical that was actually published
by prisoners at rikers island
from i think 1939
to 1940 something
and i was thinking about
you know what
was required in order to um
be able to do that this is for those of
you who don't remember
a period when we didn't have xeroxing
or
you know i looked at it and i said this
was
mimeograph
well i think that's the way that was the
word mimeograph
uh and uh the prisoners who put this
together and the books that they had to
read in order to put
this literary publication together
was was was quite astounding so i'd
really like to thank the
librarians for allowing me to
see these documents and i also had a
brief conversation
with
um
what is his name the head of the
correctional
what's his name
what's his name
nicholas nicholas okay that's right you
were there too
with nicholas
who
uh
coordinates relations between the new
york public library
and
the and rikers island
and the women's and the men's detention
facility there interesting so i was
actually telling him about
my experience in the women's house of
detention here in new york i'm having
all of these new york memories
you know this
[Laughter]
and
i um
you know i was in jail in new york
i don't know did you mention that i was
in jail
okay okay some people don't know
and
one of the first places i went
i was able to go in the jail was the
library
and i didn't see very many interesting
books
there
right
i mean i
had just finished my studies in
philosophy and i went to the library
expecting something very different
and so what i did was i had people send
books to me while i was there and i
wanted to share those books with all of
the other women there was something like
a thousand women
there and i was not allowed to do that
as a matter of fact in the library there
was a big cardboard box you could
receive the books i could receive the
books and i could read the books myself
it was okay
yeah for me to read them but don't share
them but don't share them
and one of them was george jackson's
book oh yeah soledad brothers that was
not allowed at all although
we did
you know one of the things i learned
when i was in jail there was you know
how to
secrete
certain kinds of things
and so we were able to
[Laughter]
so we had these clandestine
reading groups with books that were
smuggled out of that box in the library
yeah
and it kind of reminded me of frederick
douglass and frederick douglass's effort
to
get an education to learn how to read
and
and and his idea that um
education really was liberation
absolutely yeah that scene that i'm sure
people who read the autobiography of his
of the master saying don't
teach him in the mistress
wanting to but being afraid to he uses
an ir
interesting phrase in describing
her
which was
irresponsible power right right
and i thought that's just not just
having the power
it's the irresponsibility of how you
manage it
and his hunger
was overwhelming
because he knew as we all know that that
was freedom
and the people who did not want blacks
to read
knew that i mean that's why
you know if it had been
you know simple fairy stories it would
have been quite different or not even
that
there is power if you can't read in your
in a place like that they can
cheat you and beat you
and the other route is extraordinary
um
the things people suffered in order
to read i remember in
in trying to figure this out with in a
novel i wrote a mercy
how would that child learn to read well
she was in
maryland
which was a state charles bought king
charles as a haven for catholics
who were being beaten up
and killed and persecuted in during the
restoration in england
the catholics had a different idea about
the soul
of black people than protestants some
protestants did
and
not that the consequences were terribly
thrilling but they just sort of reshaped
the definition of uh
what what is a human being or who is the
other
and so that priests would frequently
defy
the virginians for example who were
church of england people
and teach
people to read slaves to read children
to read
not that they wanted them to read the
bible but just so that they could do the
catechism and perhaps read
some religious tracts
so there was
that kind of priest
in addition to other kinds which would
not teach you to read but there were
exceptions in the way in which they
interpreted
enslaved people
and i also wanted to emphasize in in
that book
i wanted to separate race
from slavery
it wasn't really the same thing
we assumed all slaves were black and
that just not was not true
they called white slaves indentured
servants
in order to give them uh legitimate uh
they want chattel slavery although they
function that way if you had an
indentured servant you could extend
their contract forever
any little infraction you could add
another seven years and if they drop
dead and happen to have children
you could
use the child to pay off the debt
and there were many instances in which
white indentured
europeans
work right alongside
black slaves on plantations
and i always remark on this one incident
in that book and what i learned was this
thing called bacon's rebellion
where a group was called the people's
army some landed gentry
some indentured servants and some black
slaves and some native americans
indigenous people all you know
got together
and
deposed the governor of virginia
and they ran things for a month they
weren't so nice themselves but still
i don't want you to think there was this
noble group
going forth they were just another group
uh anyway when the governor returned
from england they killed them all but
the interesting thing is
that
they established these laws
and the laws were very very interesting
they said things like
any no blacks shall be allowed to carry
a weapon
ever for any circumstances
second any white
can maim or kill any black
for any reason
without
being charged
now you see what that did to the
indentured servants who were white
now they're better
freer
more powerful they're the same situation
they're still enslaved but they're not
but they can carry weapons and they can
beat up
black slaves without punishment so they
have this little margin
of status
nothing else nothing else
but that little margin and that little
margin has worked its way through this
country since then
that was in the 17th century
and you know
the southern strategy you know all these
things
in which you
you know flag race and racism
as a cause or even a goal
you know racism is not a goal
it's a path
it's just a root
the power
and money
that's what it is that's what it's for
whether it's via war or segregation or
what have you
the thing itself is just a manipulation
and a tool
and it's
purpose
is
um what i just described that went on
after the bacon rebellion
so how did i get there
well you know i was thinking as you as
you were describing um as you would
we're describing the conditions then
that
um when you were talking about a mercy
[Laughter]
i was thinking about um
you know frederick douglass's
did that another passage in the
narrative
where he kept hearing this word
abolition
and he didn't know what it meant
and he heard about the abolitionist but
he had no idea what it meant and he said
that at some point he realized
that
it was connected to something that he
really ought to be interested in
and then eventually i mean he describes
this painstaking process of learning
you know learning how to write and you
know learning how to read and learning
how to write by
looking at the markings
that
were placed on the boards
to be used to build ships
so one would say something
forward starboard f
s
and then he learned those letters fs as
everything right it's amazing and and
then of course he talks about uh bribing
um the white boys to teach him
how
to read and write he says at one point
he dares the a a a white boy who was
around
to prove that he could write better than
frederick douglass himself could now
frederick douglass really didn't know
how to write that much
so the white boy could write a lot more
and in the process he learns what the
white boy was writing uh
so um but the point that i was making
about hearing this word and knowing
there was something about this word
that was so important yeah but he had no
idea what it meant
but he was attracted to it yeah it was
like abolition
abolitionist sounds right
and then of course he becomes uh the
most powerful abolitionist yes
but that kind of curiosity that really
is only possible um
through a process of education
you know where
which isn't to say that people who don't
know how to read and write don't have
that curiosity but learning how to read
and write opens up a whole new universe
opens up a whole new dimension and this
is why these texas people did not want
the president
yes exactly exactly yeah
why paradise i mean really
and then you know when you consider that
there are now 2.5 million people behind
bars
and what can they really do
what can they do that significant uh
uh you know reading and and writing
really allows
for the possibility of inhabiting a very
different
world but the control of those 245
million people
i don't know about all but
it's such a profit-making
thing now yeah i mean you you have whole
cities i know in upstate new york
that are living off of the benefits of a
brand new prison
employment of the guards the cooks this
you know all the paraphernalia that goes
with
imprisonment and i don't know how they
oh i read about somebody one of those
prisons in texas privately prisons where
the business get out no money
when the prisons get out they get no
they owe they owe money oh because
yeah because they have to pay they have
to pay for their own room and board
right yeah they're in college yeah
yeah it's just like the students right
[Laughter]
room and forty you get out and you have
this bill if your family can't pay you
none of you paid your in time for
whatever and then of course the kinds of
laws
that are you know
heavily weighted in certain communities
for minor
offenses and so on not to speak of
um
but i was interested in your in your
book because
i'm not sure i understand fully that
separation
well that's not well the implication is
that there's a difference
well there is a difference between
vengeance and justice
[Music]
but justice itself has some
unpleasant
consequences
um
we have to assume
that if we want justice for some bad
activity by a bad person
we want punishment we want restraint
we don't want rehabilitation
and that assumes that
there is something called the other
there's a stranger
that your neighbor or the criminal the
so-called criminal
is some other thing
is an
other
now i was thinking
along those lines
when i was trying to figure out
another area that is of great interest
to me and has always been but i've never
had the patience or maybe the
intelligence or maybe the research kind
of follow it through
which is what the impact
of
torture
and slavery enslavement
and
violence has on the perpetrator
i don't therapists don't seem to be
terribly interested in that
but my feet when i mention the other
possibility it seems to me
that when you destroy
somebody
through
vengeance
and or
severe forms of justice
that the real
object
of the pain
really is the self
don't have to go there with me but
that's
you really you know that's why it's so
the menace is so mundane in a way
so i'm thinking about these slave owners
i'm thinking about say women enslaved
women who were pregnant
lying on the ground they make a hole for
her stomach so they and then they beat
her or any other you know sort of savage
response
uh that even the one that frederick
douglass speaks of
it's very clear in his case when he
finally confronts that uh
covey covey
uh who is kavi i mean
he's he's destroying something that is
in himself
it's not that that person is animal or
soulless or
inferior
if you're strong enough
you know it's it's the fragile
personality
the fragile personality not strong
but the fragile almost erasable
personality that can do that
because there's already the self
contempt
and the self-loathing
and it's in that area that i
well i don't know i couldn't say i'm
working
but
i'm just looking at these various forms
it's so easy
racism obviously is the easiest thing
you can do it's very easy to uh block
off these so-called criminals and
they're away from us they're not with us
we don't even have to be tolerant
because they're over there but if
they're us
if we're doing that in order to corral a
certain kind of behavior
whether it's
scale is high or low
in order to uh
redeem something in ourselves that's a
whole different operation
entirely different
so i want i've read a lot a couple too
diaries of appended diaries
not these sort of little let me tell my
grandchildren what to think of me but
some interesting uh diaries um
of slave owners when they're not showing
off they're just marking how many
barrels and how many this and you know
riding up and down and sleeping with
this and so on it's really interesting
because they're not cruel i mean they do
cruel things
but they're not cruel people
but what they obviously are doing is
working out some relationship
that is so
damaging
to them
really damaging
it's really a form of self-destruction
it's a powerful form of self-destruction
that
i don't care how big the spectacle
you know whether it's germany in the 30s
and 40s it's still a spectacle and it is
about one's own self-loathing and
fragility
that you need that spectacle
well that's my lecture for today okay
well you know i would okay i i've had a
number of thoughts oh you have good one
of them i want to put in parentheses
because i want us to come back to it
and and that relates to something that
you said earlier about
the profitability of punishment
but i want us to think about the
privatization of libraries
regular party
well you know just as we have
experienced over the last
several decades of privatization of
health care
we are witnessing the privatization of
education
um and you know i won't talk about
looking for superman and or waiting for
superman whatever it's called uh the
privatization of prisons yes but
there is now a company called
libraries
services
library systems and services
that is taking over libraries in some
communities california for example
who pays for that i mean who would how
do well okay they make money they make
money because they hire
non-union staff
okay they they either
don't allow the employees to continue to
be members of the union or else they
hire and tight entirely uh a new staff
and they probably also cut back on
services because the only reason for
such a company existing is its
profitability well what about the person
who wants to go and borrow a book do i
get drafts pay a fee for
joining the library yet well you know
yeah maybe not yet but who knows what
will happen
in the future and it's it's it's very
dangerous uh
the privatization of everything is what
we're in the process of witnessing but
that's what i said i wanted to put in um
parentheses uh
the um
oh the other comment i wanted to make
was
the fact that i
i've been looking at the work of this
woman
from new york's new york her name is
faye honey knopf
she was a quaker
and
helped to publish a book
in 1976 which was called
instead of prisons that abolitionist
handbook
so she was one of the key figures in the
apple prison abolitionist movement in
the 70s she
she was a quaker who had also been
involved in the anti-war movement and
i just
saw well there's a film with yuri
koshiyama
called mountains that take wings some of
my students are here from
syracuse they saw it
and apparently and yuri koshiyama of
course was the
is a an amazing activist a
japanese american activist who was in an
in
tournament camp
and
she lived in harlem for many years and
met malcolm x and was responsible for
introducing the survivors of hiroshima
to malcolm and as a matter of fact she
was in the audubon ballroom when malcolm
was assassinated and there's this
incredible photograph of her
leaning over malcolm's body
that's yuri koshiyama the woman i'm
talking about is faye honey
knop
whose daughter told me the other day
that
her mother
feihaniknap worked with the same group
of survivors of hiroshima
that
yuri koshiyama introduced to malcolm x
so i mean it's really interesting you
know all of these
uh k-n-o-p-p
oh i cannot yes yeah
not like alfred
well the point that i want to make is
that um
she came to the conclusion after doing
all of this work on prison abolition
that um
the only way she would and the whole
movement would be able to
move in a progressive direction would be
to demonstrate
that it was possible to address
some of the horrendous problems that
imprisonment presumes to address so she
started to work with child sex abusers
child sex abusers
and she spent the rest of her life
you know working with
these
mostly men
who had sexually
abused children
because she felt that she had to answer
the hardest question
and she also felt that if we continue to
be
incapable of confronting
those
horrendous
acts of violence that human beings
inflict on each other
that it would never be possible to get
rid of the prison because what we do now
is we say
that
when someone commits such a horrible act
put them in prison where we don't have
to think about them anymore and we don't
have to think about the perpetrators
and we also don't have to think about
the problem or the problem no no and it
continues to replicate itself so in a
sense addressing it in that way
has guaranteed
that there would be this uh
reproduction of of the problem from one
generation to the next
and
you were talking about uh the
diaries of of of slaveholders and people
who committed horrendous acts and who
weren't necessarily
somebody has a cell phone that's ringing
okay we'll wait
good it's at you
[Laughter]
hi
and um
and so yeah
um
and you were saying that uh they they
weren't necessarily evil people they
committed evil acts
and
i think this is something we have a hard
time recognizing today
um somebody calls it a case of uh
mistaken identity
who says that suicide was a case of
mistaken identity
i thought that suicide that suicide
suicide is the case okay
i see i see
because you really meant to kill
somebody else yeah
you don't recognize yourself
[Laughter]
so it may be the same
[Laughter]
it may be the same thing you know in a
nutshell theatrical way
when we think
we've put that aside we don't have to
address the problem anymore and that it
does not
that that the activity whatever the
behavior is is somehow
beyond the pale it's not us you know
because
you know i'm getting a little
uh weary with that notion of the
foreigner
you know i did a whole thing at the
louvre called the foreigner's home
the foreigner is home
at the louvre in paris the foreigner
is all this is his home
he owns his home because a lot of
foreigners i mean in africa they were
treated like foreigners right
absolutely i mean that's what
colonization is you become a foreigner
and you're in your own home
and certainly it's true with
african-americans you know who have
preceded many many of the people who
came here and native americans and nato
really
have been demonized
or the foreigners own home of the
foreigner is home but the the notion of
the foreigners not just linguistic or
geographical or
community it really is a kind of
severance
deliberate
uh maybe for status maybe just because
of
of
another group
that is
not doesn't have the advantages you do
one of the reasons back to this last
completed work of mine
about a mercy was that i
know as everyone does that no one in the
world is born
with those attitudes
and prejudices no one
you can
learn them early so long as you're
taught you're in an environment in which
such ideas
can flower
but it's not in your dna
it's not natural it can become
environmentally
you know necessary or you know you live
in a certain world in which there is
none or there is
okay that inner sense
uh of the
of a human being
i wanted to compare with the
you know this romantic notion of the
innocent american americans are always
anxious you haven't noticed that
uh there are hundreds of books innocent
americans and abroad
so i want to go back before the
institutionalization to see whether
you know these were people coming from
europe for either money or resources or
they were scared to death
i mean you have to have a lot of
something horrible going on to risk two
to three months
in some raggedy ship i mean most of
those things sank
aboard you were down there you know with
the animals that's who they were really
shipping they were cows and pigs and
things and a few human beings
uh next to them and then you come to
this country
with
probably nothing
uh and it was bountiful certainly that
but what were they running from
usually religion or poverty
uh
but the point was that they did not come
over here i mean italians who came to
this country
were not italians after a while
they were white
but it took a long time it took a long
time long process of becoming white yes
it is a process
i mean
you can't just oh
then become this you see but the same
but i wanted to get back to that notion
this country
particularly with the political
flavor and poison
now
uh to to look at what it was like then
when every country wanted a piece of
this this place i mean we could be
speaking dutch now
or spanish
or
swedish did you know there was a swedish
empire i didn't
i mean they were all in here doing what
they did you know obviously in africa
taking little bits to claiming this
town's names changed every five years
somebody else would say no no no it's
not
new york it's
this
uh it's not this it said they changed
names constantly but that was the big
thing but the people who were settling
here who were really refugees
uh came here with some other ideas
so what made this outrageous um
the necessity
uh for the level of enslavement and
racism in this country was what i said
money and profit i mean
we this country entered the industrial
revolution like in i don't know three
decades
other countries took a century
this country in three decades why
because they had slave labor
instantly you don't have to pay them you
have to do anything just feed them and
corral them
and then you look at some place where
they were making sugar in cuba and the
people were dropping they kept bringing
slaves over bringing slaves over it was
a little island
why did they need so many
you get you know i don't know a thousand
slaves to cut
sugar or 2000 or what why were they key
then i learned that they were dropping
dead
they died so when guys get another
that's right you just replenish them
they come over here and live a year
yeah
or two they try to get younger and
younger ones right live four years so
you're replenishing them
like putting coal into a furnace
so that all of this is
my trying to figure out
uh not just the consequences of race
which i did in the first book i wrote
the blue stein but other things around
it
since it seems to
uh you know have a hole these have to be
ferociously
against it or
apologetic about it or you are the
victim of it or the perpetrator of it
and i just want to get rid of that
discourse which doesn't go anywhere and
find out what the origins are uh what
its purpose is
not just a scapegoat purpose but it has
a real function
which is
power and control
and money which is pretty much the same
thing
that's what it's for
it's not something that oh yeah
i
this group of people are like this and i
mean you know we all know that's
ridiculous
and that's why the phrase but one of my
best friends is because we all know one
who's not quite like that
uh and that's part of the staple you
know i'm not really you know but there's
something
in the in the diet
yeah the intellectual diet
and the ignorance you know
of uh
well-meaning people and even their own
work
and i was serious when i said i don't
understand why therapists ignore it or
ignore it the way they do
that's a powerful thing you know
in the mind
angela's experience in the library and
somebody else was talking about having
difficulty going into life it was like
alice um alice walker yes yeah and then
she just could not because
she said that
she finds it difficult to
enter into libraries today i was um
so hungry for the experience of the
library that i never experienced that
difficulty
and i haunted libraries all over the
world for a very long time but uh tony
if they were my home my my first decent
job other than scrubbing somebody's
floors at 12 was to be a page
in the library which i got because my
sister was secretary to the head
librarian
so she brought me in and they quickly
they didn't fire me because i was very
slow
i mean you read the book
so they just moved me to another
department
[Music]
okay tony before you move on there's i
have a response uh
that i want to share
because
liz i always loved listening to you talk
and i could and i realized that i'm also
here to participate in the conversation
so i can't just sit back like i usually
do
and i'm sorry you know all of your
brilliance
but i you know this this summer i was in
um
colombia as a matter of fact in
september columbia columbia colombia
and
visited a community of people
outside of kali
who live
in this mountainous area
afro-descended people
people whose ancestors were enslaved 400
years ago
who were brought to colombia to engage
in gold mining
they still live in the place where their
ancestors settle
when they
escaped slavery so it was initially a
fugitive slave settlement like a maroon
settlement and this the people who live
there now
um
live on the same land and do the same
work
that their ancestors did 400 years ago
they still
mine gold in this
very
different way the women are minors
and the children are minors and the
women talk about mining in this
incredibly passionate way
the guy's mind too
they all mine
they oh my no but i mean it's
interesting that the women say i've been
a miner since i was in my mother's womb
uh so the point that i'm making is that
now um even though they actually own the
land they have the they they were able
to get the title to the land but not to
what's
in the land the subsoil the minerals
and there are a number of big mining
concerns that are trying to evict them
so that they can institute these new
industrialized modes of mining strip
mining
and
one of the mining companies this kind of
complicates our notion of what counts as
racism in this day and age and its
relationship to power
one of one of the mining companies is
called
anglo-gol ashanti
and it is headquartered in south africa
the ceo of the mining company is a black
south african
so
there you go
yeah there we go there we go
and it's it's it's it's also about uh
the way in which racism um has a
has its own um dynamic and its own
momentum
regardless of what who the people are or
what the people think
i mean here's a black south african who
just
how long ago experienced
freedom
from apartheid in south africa and who
is now about to kick these people off
their land people who've lived on the
same land for 400 years
so what kind of a story is that
everybody should write the new president
of colombia we will yes that's one thing
we can all do uh this evening what is
his name um
he just got elected um
we'll find it what's his name not you
uribe was was the last president and a
new president was elected just uh a
month or so ago
what's his name
santos
yes that's right santos santos
but you can google it you can get it you
know really well right and write a
letter write a letter of protest that's
right
ah what time is it
so
do we want to take any questions from
the audience
a few okay well it's about uh wow it's
it's a little after eight now how long
have we been talking about about five
minutes a little less than about 55
minutes so yeah
okay so we'll take a few questions
that'll be good
[Music]
thank you
i want to apologize for that phone it
was from
death row in pennsylvania
oh wow
[Music]
if we're talking about prisons and
talking about inhumanities
and how we are being deprived of so many
brilliant minds that are in prison that
should be
helping to lead the country can we talk
about
mumia
and the all the political prisoners that
are in prison who should be amongst us
please
well first
uh i would say
um
[Music]
that
you know speaking of literacy
and libraries and liberation uh mumia
abu jamal has made such an amazing
contribution
to all all three of those those
categories
and
yeah this is something that we we have
we have to
save mumia's life we have to save
mumia's life
and this is it's also about the
relationship between
learning
and freedom
uh it's about the uses to which we put
our
literacy
and because of the fact that there's
been this mobilization against mumia by
law enforcement all over the country it
has not been possible to build the kind
of campaign
that we see in other parts of
of the world as a matter of fact mia is
an honorary citizen of paris
and there's streets named after him in
all over europe in
germany everyone knows his name
and that's why
if he were like stupid and sort of un
right
right but what can we do here yeah where
can we that's that's a question a good
question what can we do
where in philadelphia
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
a big demonstration on november 9th okay
[Music]
okay
and also i think we have to do the work
um
that needs to be done to build movements
that is to
use all of your contacts to
encourage people to think about this
case
tell people about
mumia
if you have kids who are in school
you know ask
the teachers to talk to the children
about the meaning of living in a
democrat
so-called democratic society
and using
capital punishment as a routine
mode of addressing a whole range of
issues this is the only industrialized
democracy in the entire world
that puts people to death in this way
and mamia more than anyone has been the
face of the campaign
to expand democracy in this country to
abolish capital punishment and the death
penalty so thank you thank you very much
good evening my name is kazimbe um and
uh first thing i want to say is that um
the women's house of detention is now
the jefferson market library uh which i
think is really ground like great
market yeah on 10th avenue
10th street and 6th avenue so that's
awesome um
my question is um you um professor
morrison you mentioned the self and i'm
wondering if that can also translate
into the current
um anger that we see in terms of
immigrants and also but specifically
around
the gay youth suicides and bullying as
well
and i'm wondering if there's any thought
in terms of the connection between
gender expression and the race in terms
of the hatred of the self in terms of
your research in terms of mercy but also
i know professor mo davis you've also
done a ton of research on that as well
if you can comment on that
that's clear to me
the answer homophobia
it's so obviously
violence connected with that it's so
obviously a destruction of the self i
mean it's just blatant you know
to me these others are maybe people
don't realize it so much
but
calling people names and beating them up
uh hanging people off of fences
and what
i mean it's just so
self-destructive
you know the more vicious it is toward
the so-called homosexual
uh person
the more violence there is toward
oneself and that and i think that you
know distributes itself in other kinds
of scapegoats and
i don't know how do mexicans i mean
police
or board somebody said i read somewhere
that when the berlin wall came down
my prognostication was
uh oh the end of in theoretical not
really but the end of communism is also
the end of raw capitalism
i mean if one goes
the other goes also
and i have been proven right but the
other thing is he said you've been
proven correct
i mean capitalism is not dead
obviously but it's crumbling well but
it i mean i totally it is it is it is i
told them i know it but most people
don't know it they're terrified by the
notion of not having it and and i think
that capitalism capitalism penetrates
into that's true our very emotions in
ways that it was never able to do
that's true and when we look about the
privatization of libraries
he's not gonna laugh you can i'm telling
you okay it's tell me uh it's decaying
okay how does that mean
how do you scramble how do we speed up
the demise of capitalism that's what i
want to know
the first thing you have to do is keep
those republicans out of office
yeah because they're hanging on
tooth and nail
yeah
to
you know capitalism and its rawest form
not even its sort of civilized form but
the raw er the better so that's one way
but
you know
i may not live to see it i'd be 80 next
year but you will my dear
i'm not that far behind
so that's one thing oh the berlin wall
is interesting is when the berlin wall
fell this is how we talk all the time
all sorts of other walls went up
the one between israel and the west bank
and then the wall in
south
mexico that
is a border
i mean all these other walls jumped up
and then they're not physical walls but
there are other kinds of imprisonment
walls i mean we're just constantly
separating in some instances the berlin
wall was so people couldn't get out
now we're building walls so they can't
get in
so you know it's a constant
this shift looks to me long range
like part and parcel of what i am
certain is
you know this it's the disconnect you
know it's really crumbling when these
people say i want my
get out of i want the government out of
my
social security
i know i know yeah
it doesn't matter it's all incoherent
well since you're talking about since
you're talking about capitalism since
you're talking about capitalism and
communism i want to acknowledge charlene
mitchell who's sitting over there
[Applause]
charlene was the first black woman to
run for the office of the president of
the united states of america
she was on the communist party
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes
dear you know i was actually my first
job was also a page in the library on
96th street and i'm also a writer so
you've made me feel really good tonight
about my prospects for accomplishment
my question is i actually have two
questions and one is um it's about your
ideas around
visual literacy i immediately thought
about movies particularly in the context
of how movies now
are being adapted from books and the
type of literacy that we get from movies
versus what we get from the book it's
always
i would hope the director is walking a
fine line although even with something
like epray love
the general masses were outraged i think
that becomes even more complicated when
you talk about black black movies about
black women in black movies particularly
like
alice walker's the color purple waiting
to exhale and now we have for color
girls coming up and i just wanted to
know your thoughts on
on adaptation um and and film and also
that and just if you could flush out
some more of your ideas in terms of
visual literacy in the realm of
film adapted from books my second
question is a lot easier how did you two
meet um and how did you end up
writing her uh editing her autobiography
oh it's the opposite way around
yeah exactly
thanks i don't know what she was doing
i had a job at random house
and she was an acquisition that they
were very proud of
and so we got to know each other at that
point i think i had published one book
or two you had published blue science
yes already other times and you were
working on um
no you had already published so you were
working on sound songs solomon i had
published because i can remember you
would like write three or four lines uh
we would we would be driving from your
house to the city across the george
washington bridge uh there would be
traffic you'd pull out a little notepad
and write or you'd fix breakfast for a
slave and dino and then you'd write a
little bit here
and then when the book finally came out
i said
i cannot believe it
you know it was so it was like
[Applause]
it's
magical
but also i really i should say that i
really appreciate
what i learned about writing from
tony when i read when i wrote my
autobiography you know i was somebody
who was used to writing
philosophy
and so i didn't think about writing in
the same way
and you know rather than like writing it
for me tony would say
well
you know what was that room like
you know what did it look like what was
in there what were the colors and so she
made me
understand writing in such a a different
way and i'm forever grateful
for that we also had fun you remember
when we went to
the virgin islands
and i made you and i made you walk from
one end of the island to the other
there was nowhere
there was nowhere in the united states
where angela could feel safe and right
so
so we went to the virgin islands
for a long time it's like a month or
something yeah we stay yeah well we work
because i remember we were going to stay
at the holiday inn hotel but it wasn't
finished yet
when we got it it was incomplete so we
were yeah yeah yeah and we also went to
uh remember we went to finland and
um sweden and denmark helsinki hilton
yeah yeah yeah remember the
photographers came out and these women
was that in helsinki
these women
uh formed a circle
huge circle they held hands with angela
in the middle and i was sort of there
but
looking around to keep the photographers
and the journalists all right right
right cops or whoever yeah they just
formed this tights it was amazing yeah
yeah i should have had a camera you know
what i mean
but see this is this was really really
wonderful
well how we met each other the question
was visual literacy too so well i think
what
movies and adaptations yes and what do i
think i think that most of them are
pretty
awful
[Laughter]
there's some
i don't know if it's fear
of doing something you know how creative
say african-americans have been with
music
i mean
nobody told them how to do it
i was just reading about bob
coming out right after the atom bomb
it was so chaotic i mean everybody's
building shelters and saying oh my god
what is this the music changed right
away
into something that were you know odd
notes screeches new language you know
they just took off anyway back to the
movie thing it's this very
it's as though they're fearful of
powerful and different creativity
how to do something wildly different or
they follow a certain pattern
you know
i mean you know from the first scene
everything
now i understand that the business
requires certain kinds of formulas
in order for to get the money
and to get them out i understand that
it's a it's such an expensive project
i'm surprised anybody does anything i
was stunned looking at
this doesn't have to
do with
african-american films
but i saw
what's that
no country for old man
my god there was a movie with no score
none
i didn't have to they didn't tell me
dante
[Music]
i mean i just blew his head off you know
or something like that with no sound
there was just some mexicans
you know on the guitar that's all you
heard
it was thrilling it's like they trusted
me you know it's frightening it was
different but i wasn't
urged by the music
pushed this is going to be scary this is
going to be happy this is going to be
you know
and i thought isn't that interesting
so that's a little bit i know about the
movies but what i'm saying is that
i wish it were possible
to do more
inventive creative
non-formulaic hollywood things
it's possible in the movies
hey think about passing strange
wasn't that something
i have never seen anything on broadway
that literate
and that musically inventive and staged
that way that was really a leap for me
i thought it was fantastic so it is
possible and i just want to say that
you know i've been unhappy
oh who cares not unhappy but
you know not
wholly excited by and not satisfied by
a lot of the films and musicals are
going on although they're well
intentioned
for me well-intentioned and good enough
it's like happiness
that ain't good enough
don't rest on happiness
it's okay i hope you all are happy but
we got to do more than that
more than that
yes
hello first of all let me just say this
is an incredible honor
and just to be in front of two
of my literary and life heroes i'm about
to have my own breakdown without even
reading
paradise but i have two questions as
well
the first being
you talked about you know writing a
letter to colombia and talking about
in protest to what's going on with the
minors there what do you think in this
time where it seems like lethargy and
cynicism has
risen so high it's almost you know
choking us
how do you feel what do you think
the role of written protest is i mean is
it still does it still have an effect
the written letter of protest
the other question i have is also in
these times
what do you think the role or the
importance of the storyteller is
well andrea i want you to answer both of
those questions
[Laughter]
but i have to say preface my obviously
you know we live in this fast food
nation yeah
americans just want it now
and a lot yeah and they sort of like
deserve it
you know politically
everything
and with all the problems
if you don't hand it to him right this
minute
like at mcdonald's you know you just
drive by
tell the little machine what you want
pay them in the money
get your mood and going home
and it seems like that is you know this
sort of constant thing so that actually
sitting down and writing a letter
mailing it
telling three other people to do the
same thing
and organize like actually get on the
phone call some people you know it takes
too long
uh who's gonna cut you know it's like it
may take a while
it may take a while that's my version
okay well
i totally agree with you
um because we've forgotten how to write
letters
you know i mean i was going to say for
those of you who um
will have problems actually sitting down
and doing a letter and putting it in
um the mail you know finding out how
much it costs to mail a letter you
yeah right and all of that uh
you could perhaps
figure out how to email him
but
let me see if i if i can answer that
question in um
a slightly more complicated way
and it has to do with the previous
discussion we were having about
capitalism
and the extent to which we
assume
that as individuals we are powerless
which is in part
a consequence of
neoliberal
individualistic ideology that we only
think of ourselves
as individuals and that we don't think
about possible connections uh broader
connections with communities that are
not only in the us but that are that are
in other parts of the world as well
and it seems to me that this is the real
challenge of of this period
even for people who consider themselves
progressive in a country like the united
states of america
because we also
are
we also imagine ourselves as somewhat
different from the rest of the people in
the world
you know american exceptionalism has its
impact even on those who
pretend to be most radical exactly
um
and so what would it take what would it
take to create
a connection
with
that community
i was speaking about there are about
seven thousand people
afro-descended colombians many of whom
still have african names
because they have created a history and
a culture that goes back to
that goes back to resistance against
slavery and they're still resisting as a
matter of fact they received an eviction
order for august 18th and they refused
to leave
so yeah you've and writing to answer
your question is
written protests is a process that can
perhaps help us feel as if we are making
community
we are reaching out beyond ourselves and
and that we have emotional connections
with people who live on this mountain
and this is in in in this
village called lactoma
well i have this mantra
in connection with what you said angela
when i was young
they called us citizens
we were american citizens or we were
fighting for citizenship we were first
class or second class
but the word was citizen now citizens
suggest some relationship with your
neighbors with the bloc with town with
the village
after world war ii they stopped using
that word
and we were consumers
that's all you could hear american
consumer this the american consumer that
and we bought things for status and that
what we were supposed to do
now
what are we we are taxpayers
all of a sudden it's about my little tax
my little money i don't want to give it
to the i don't want those people who
should not have it you know the people
you know we've and that you talk about
capitalism sort of seeping into the
blood they just change the language
and redefine us and we go for it yes my
driver was fussing about his taxes i
said so what
you pay taxes so what
and
um but you know so all of a sudden we
lose who we are
or we we're redefined and when you when
the language changes we change
the labels change so all of a sudden
it's about taxes if i have something
else about taxes
but if we were still
citizens
that's a different thing
we feel some obligation
we don't pass by citizenship not
narrowly defined no largely and there
are no losers i remember when hobos were
romantic
they were hemmingway stories
and they were on these trains and they
did stuff
now they're the homeless losers
who by the way don't pay taxes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's taking his head
hi there
actually there were some great blues
players that are out there on the
railroad track playing some fantastic
fantastic music
ladies this is honor
i could see your hand up with a fro
and on a book that i have
that i was looking for and you bought um
ida b wells alive for me
i did yes you did yeah
and you
apollo giddings it was a um
it was a program didn't you oh yeah yeah
me and paula
she wrote the book oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
correct
it's my memory well you know can i just
say something
many people
don't acknowledge
um how important
toni morrison
uh was to the emergence of what we now
call a black feminist literature that's
true and
and i just
i mean i say this to my students i don't
know what i've ever said it to you but
uh i i i remember when she was
publishing tony kate bambara
right
and
and um gail jones
lucille clifford yeah
so you know what we know as that as that
black women's writing that took shape in
the 70s and the 80s would not have been
possible had not toni morrison insisted
as an editor at random house
on publishing these works
so let's
and you published paula gettings was it
paula getting and she published paula
getting's first book too yeah paula
getting's first book yeah
you know angela's first book my first
book yeah oh man
[Laughter]
she didn't realize that she was uh doing
she didn't i was just really historic
and in case there was a hiatus
i sort of was writing in between myself
you know
i didn't like that at all
they didn't hire me to write books they
hired me to edit them but what can i say
okay sorry i interrupted you no
you got you're exactly where i wanted
you
speculative
literature fiction
sci-fi
um
how does it relate to the
third world
women
and the movement through literature
as a student of anthropology i'm always
rooted into
what's real
but um i look for fiction for ideas to
make what's real
illicit you know uh illuminating
um show me the reverse where's where
where are we in the third world writing
back
speculative
soft sci-fi
about what's going on socially
well there's not much as sci-fi as
octavia butler listen you've got
somebody coming here
this is a good story i don't hope i'm
steal her thunder edward's dentica
and she's just published this book
called creative dangerously create
dangerously or something like that
anyway she gave a speech
at princeton
and she was
describing something that happened in
haiti
i was overwhelmed by this and i hope it
answers your
part of your question
she said that during the really tough
times in haiti when the two thor malcolm
was running around chopping everybody up
um
they established a rule that if somebody
died your son your neighbor a stranger
on the street
if you know they killed him you could
not pick them up
you could not go and get the body
just even if it was yours i mean a
relative
at some point a few days later
a uh
garbage truck
would come along and pick it up and put
it in the garbage and do whatever they
did
so if you went out to pick up a body
uh
to bury it or to whatever you would get
shot
so everybody was afraid
she i hope i'm not miss i know this is
part of what she said at some point in a
neighborhood
and somebody organized a little theater
in a garage
and the local people came to participate
in this play some to be in it and some
to watch it and they did it every night
and the two terminal crew would come by
and check you know to see what they were
doing and walk on by
but what they were doing
get this
the play
was antigone
i mean that to me was the most
extraordinary thing
it provided the solace
it was about the subject
the conflict between the government and
the burial of the honor of you know and
so on and so i was thinking
not only about your
inquiry but also about the the visual
literacy thing the many many ways
there's no one way the letter is a
beautiful thing
and important and permanent i mean it's
there
uh it can't be erased it can be burnt
but not you know erased off your thing
the same thing is with theater
the same thing is with portraits
i mean the same thing is just
as we were saying try to think what it's
like in the world if you can't read
what other kinds of things jump out at
you you know use everything
everything
you know to become
you know the best human being you can be
you know i also just uh noticed the
lights are on now
and i noticed that um amir
baraka is in the house
there he is right there look look he's
behind us
thank you
[Laughter]
yes
good evening i'm very honored to to be
standing in front of you you you are my
idols
i represent the resistance in new york
city the black and latina
mothers who
believe in public education who
use the libraries who are so opposed to
mayoral control into
the privatization
of
our schools
and
i want to give a shout out to the
parents in chicago who have just sat in
for a month in order to get a library
for their children
there there was a field house that was
going to be torn down and they
they sat in because they wanted a
library i'm speaking to you because as i
said you're my idols and i was greatly
influenced in the 70s and 80s in
the the literature and being able to use
now
the internet to be able to hear
you give speeches and to speak in front
of like the new york women's agenda or
the ms foundation or the new york
women's foundation where
mothers like me
women in the community
don't have access
and so i'm asking now if you can give
the women the the many the mothers
agenda new york the the women that i
represent can you please give us some
words of encouragement and inspiration
so that we take that back to the
community
and we continue our fight our our
struggle for proper quality human
rights-based education public education
for our children
[Applause]
yeah give me your email and let me say
let me say that
what you said in that
minute that took you
that it took you to explain who you were
i'm sure inspired so many of the people
here and the work that you're doing
to resist privatization
[Music]
so
the message that that i would give to
you to take back was the continued doing
what you're doing and
you know we all need we need to follow
your leadership
we need to all be involved in this
campaign to
prevent private the juggernaut of
private privatization from taking over
our lives
and especially from
taking over the
public educational system
so thank you thank you very much
thank you you're welcome don't forget
hi hi this is a question for angela
before we saw the shepherd fairy image
of obama
even you know
in the context of all these che guevara
shirts you have this iconic image of
angela davis i'm wondering how does it
feel when you see people
you know using it in posters putting it
on t-shirts does it feel like it's you
does it feel like it's co-opting your
image or does it feel like it's
spreading sort of what you were trying
to say
well okay i'll you know i'll i'll tell
you a story
because it it did
begin to bother me somewhat now the it's
so easy to
[Music]
create the possibilities of uh
proliferating image you know anybody can
do a t-shirt and uh and then it goes on
the internet and so i was i was i was a
bit disturbed by that and i asked a
young woman
um who was a high school student who had
on one of those t-shirts i said you know
what's the whole point why are you
wearing that i mean i thought that went
out in the 70s when
because then there was a reason the
reason was to help to create this
campaign to free me exactly
so i said but this is the 21st century
and she says well i wear this t-shirt
because it makes me feel powerful
it makes me feel like i can do anything
i want to do
and i don't know what she knew about
whether she knew anything about me
really
but uh that made me recognize that
people bring their own interpretations
and that that image is an image not so
much of me as an individual as it is of
an era during which uh
millions of people came together you
know all over the world and demanded my
freedom as a matter of fact charlene
mitchell was the um
was the executive
director of the national united
committee to free angela davis
so
so yeah
i mean i can't stop it
so you know why not see uh what is uh
what what might be a possible
a productive and positive in
interpretation
so you know who knows i i i do get kind
of upset when people uh think that i'm
the only
only black woman who ever wore a natural
i mean
you know i can remember when i was a
high school student in new york and and
i saw miriam akiva and i saw i saw um
odetta yeah yeah
and then later of course
tony had a natural a beautiful natural
so why why do they keep picking on me
that i don't understand
but thank you for the question
hi it's a pleasure
i'm here representing my concordia
classmates and professors and i want to
ask you what classmates concordia oh
college
um i would like to ask you if you think
um
which is worth being internally
imprisoned or being imprisoned by
society and do you think it is possible
to be internally free while being
imprisoned by society i'm referring to
slavery
and
just being in prisons
recently and things like that
thank you
you're really asking about
freedom yeah
internal external
i um
have a very small short answer about
internal
freedom
i'm from
ohio
near
no kidding
they always
uh
they always tend they come to new york
and make good make good
uh
near on lake erie right it's a
working
uh class town that had
steel mills shipyards and so on so a lot
of people came there
african-americans from the south and
mexicans and europeans and so on
i mean a real
diverse as they say in the rural
community the only common thread we had
was poverty
but again we were citizens in some cases
um
and you know
the polish lady next door would bring us
those little cabbage things with meat in
them you know okay
if she if we didn't have any and if we
had something you know we'd bring her
and everybody had gardens i'm not trying
to make it sound like it was thrilling
because but although we were too young
to know we were miserable so
at any rate um
my experiences about race
are very different from
many other black people
one is because i grew up in a mixed
neighborhood
it didn't mean people didn't call me
names but you know they were calling
each other names so what i remember
coming home with somebody some little
boy called me a bad a wicked name and
said
he said you ethiopian you
she said well ethiopia is a continent in
africa and this and
and i think the original human beings
were born there or something and we all
can and so i thought what is he talking
about you know
so that so but here's the thing um
there were little minor
things like that and some sometimes from
adults but i never felt and this is
curious i
i think i know why but i never felt
it
the way it was meant
and i think the reason is
because i always thought that those
people were deficient in some way
always even as a little one i thought
they were deficient
i had a big sort of racial
moment when i was working
as for some white family just before i
got my job as a page
i was working after school just doing
housework
and two dollars a week
one of which went to my mother
and the other i could keep but
um
she had
some complicated uh for me complicated
equipment like vacuum cleaners
never saw one
and the stove that had the other thing
and i didn't know how to work it so she
would curse me out every now and then it
doesn't matter you know and i
told my mother mom when i got to quit
she's too mean my mother said quit
now but that one dollar right
so i told my father and he said
i said daddy she's so mean
and he said go to work
get your money
and come on home
you don't live there
so i hadn't didn't have an
employment problem
since it was not my life was not
there and also i didn't have to disdain
or be afraid of or neglect any person
who had an advantage skin advantage over
me whoever they were
i never felt that
and when i wrote the first book i wrote
the bluest eye i really wanted to know
why that girl felt so bad the one who a
real life girl
who said
she wanted blue eyes we were talking
about
whether god existed
i of course was persuaded that he did
and she was persuaded that he did not
her proof
was that she had
prayed for blue eyes
for two years
two years
and she didn't get them so obviously he
wasn't up there
but when i looked at her and thought
about how awful
she would look
[Music]
if she got them
and then i thought the second thing was
how beautiful she was
at that moment you know
she was just incred but i didn't even
know whether she was beautiful or not
until i thought about what she might
think then the third thing of course is
why does she want that you know what
what makes her think
that's an improvement and that kind of
self-loathing which is real
you know in when you don't have any
support made me
you know think of
that as a as a real subject for a book
not some old victim but really how it
works
how you can actually hear someone lost
the training of the question but
it was about freedom too so all right so
i
that internal thing
i had trouble
when i first went travel south
not with white people i mean yeah maybe
but my
inability to perceive
how
southern blacks who work
you know their whole lives were
oppressed like not feeling comfort not
being able to go into the library
i mean just anything like that no not
knowing you know is this place safe or
is that place safe or knowing what the
safe places are
and what that might do how to escape
from that how does one internalize that
or does one you see
and if you do
how does it you know how do you get rid
of it
so all those and i but i never i always
thought
that the
those people whether they were adults or
children it's like they call me
ethiopian that was like
so stupid
he had sort of complimented me in a way
that i could not you know feel the
degradation that i was supposed to feel
all the self-loathing and i always felt
that inside
which i suppose is called
arrogance or
happily but i think it was the way in
which
uh
my family responded to that and they
were both from the south
deep south alabama and georgia
but they instilled in us some other
thing
okay
maybe i could just add um
a couple of things
is this the last question no no please
add some please i'll add something
well
and it's actually on a different kind of
register
uh
about freedom
um
internal freedom external freedom
what do we mean by freedom
and we've been talking about frederick
douglass and
freedom had a certain
um historical meeting then it was about
abolishing
slavery
and
as
as i thought about
this new edition of
the narrative of the life of frederick
douglass i thought it would be
important to point out that
in a sense
as incredible and as brilliant as
frederick douglass was his
imagination of freedom was historically
constricted
so that a lot of ways it was about
manhood
and and and that fight with kavi
proves his manhood and in the process
it provides a path towards freedom so
the question is well you know what about
what about women
yeah what about little girls how how
could they imagine freedom
um
and so i want to say i i want to say
this and in response to one of the
earlier questions that i didn't um get
to answer about um
um homophobia and uh
the
su the suicides of of young gay people
today
and it's about how we think about
freedom and the historical
um the deeply historical character of
our own imaginings of what it means to
be free
and what you know what did it mean to be
free in frederick douglass's time what
did it mean to struggle for freedom
during the civil rights
era
you know what does it mean
to
expand our notion of freedom today and
we've talked a lot about immigrants uh
you know tony you were talking about the
wall
the uh in mexico you talked about
pal you know the palestinians so how do
we bring
palestinian freedom into our frame how
do we bring the you know freedom of
immigrants into our
into the way we imagine freedom today
how do we think about
um transgender people how do we think
about gays lesbians bisexuals within the
frame of freedom and what does that tell
us
about the
extent to which our own framework
of freedom is
quite
restrictive
uh so i ask myself sometimes
a hundred years from now
how are people going to be
talking about the struggle
for freedom because i don't think we're
ever going to get there i don't think we
will ever reach a point where we can say
we are free
right we can rest
we can stop now
uh we've won
and so it seems that in the very process
of of struggling for freedom of
reflecting on freedom of writing about
freedom
we
constantly challenge the framework
within which we
develop
that imaginary of freedom so
i think it is it's
it's powerfully
imaginative in a certain period it's
this and another period it's something
else
i think of freedom as
well a major part of it for me is
knowledge
maybe wisdom if you get there
but certainly knowledge
and then i'm reminded that the
first sin
genesis the sin
is knowledge
the acquisition of knowledge
that's why they get thrown out of that
little kindergarten they were in
that little playpen where they could
just sort of you know
and they said uh uh uh
you know something and the literal words
at least in one of the translations the
king james is they may become wise
so stop that
they knew
and in many other
religious forms
that's why faith and belief is so
important not knowledge faith belief
just instinct which is you know i'm not
complaining i'm just suggesting that
there's something so powerful
so attractive
so liberating
about what we call you know scheme
science knowledge
that it's you know you can't have it
which is the same sort of thing that we
were talking about with this document
from the texas correction bureau and
what angela is talking about when she
talks about the necessity of reading
literacy of all kinds under
constrained circumstances
and what
frederick douglass did uh having an
intellect like
maria in prison you know death
you know all of this works into the same
thing the big horror
they have led us to believe
is knowledge because that will set you
free
on this note of knowledge
i would like
to thank angela davis and toni morrison
thank you very much
this event was hosted by the new york
public library in new york city for more
information visit nypl.org
joining us is jonathan